[Music]
well the left is taking Supreme Court
Justice Anthony Kennedy is retirement
hard so hard in fact that some of them
want to throw out the entire
constitutional order and D legitimize
the Supreme Court itself in Samuel is a
lecturer at Harvard Law School
he's been demanding that as soon as
Democrats hold power once again they
need to expand the size of the Supreme
Court and pack it with liberals a week
ago samuel tweeted this quote pack the
courts should be a phrase on par with
abolish ice ian samuel joins us sayin
thank you for coming on hey thanks for
having me welcome from service oh of
course
wouldn't it just be easier to give
california i don't know 27 new
congressional districts in LA county and
be done with it or maybe just abolish
Congress entirely I mean if the goal is
just to increase the power of the left
why mess around the Supreme Court well
you know the thing is the I think I we
very much agree on the basic end here
which is that the Supreme Court should
not be a partisan institution subject to
sort of like ideological swings the
problem is the Supreme Court the
justices of the Supreme Court 14 out of
the last 18 have been appointed by
Republican presidents they had sort of
11 in a row before Ruth Bader Ginsburg
which is kind of a surprising and almost
remarkable achievement when you think
about it and so we're left in this
position now where the partisan balance
on the Supreme Court is way out of whack
with what people have voted for so what
I'm really in favor of is returning the
Supreme Court to being a sort of
nonpartisan institution that is set away
from the sort of fray of ideological
politics but we can't do that until we
add some seats to correct the balance
that we've loved it you're smooth I will
say that so when you tweet
I thought you what court quote pack the
court how to be up there with abolish
ice that is in fact a nonpartisan
statement somehow how does that work how
is that not how is increasing the
partisan Democratic representation on
the port indeed nonpartisan well you
know when you encounter a jewel thief
you must steal things back Tucker as I'm
sure you know and look I would
a sort of settlement once this is all
done I would love to get to a place for
example where you know maybe every
president gets two or three guaranteed
Supreme Court nominations you know maybe
we should have an even number of Supreme
Court you know ten justices five from
each party I think that would be nice it
would require a little court packing but
you know that's the art of the deal but
the reality is we're way out of whack
and it's worth it to have any hope of
moving forward with a Supreme Court
that's not this kind of ideological part
as an institution we have a little
mending fences to do so let's do it
right so in other words increase the
power of the left and everything will be
cool but as long as it's center-right in
the court I think by anybody's I mean
look if you match public opinion polling
to the issues you will see that the
court is not way out to the right at all
and I've seen it oh pretty much it's not
on the issues it is not so I do believe
it I know you don't believe that and I
know and I know you shouldn't right so
for example I don't think either of us
believe that the way that Citizens
United should come out should be subject
to a public opinion poll even though you
know as well as I do that 75 I'm not
suggesting any of the decisions right
you would agree with that but you
yourself do but you're making the
counter case it's hard you're claiming
that we need to pack the court which a
naked paragraph by the left we both know
it but you're saying we need to do that
because it would be more representative
of the public will and I'm merely noting
as a factual matter because I've seen
the numbers that the majority of recent
Supreme Court's decisions fall within
the center line of public opinion so
actually there isn't a problem other
than Democrats don't get to do their
will with the court to the extent you
wish they could well I'm not so sure
about that look I've tried to learn well
from the most accomplished politicians
of my age and to my mind the best one is
Mitch McConnell and he understood as
well as I do that control of the Supreme
Court is to paraphrase rod Blagojevich
not something you just give away right
he sort of Court shrunk for a year and a
half to eight members until there was a
president to his liking and remember
before the 2016 election Ted Cruz and
John McCain and all your beloved heroes
Tucker were saying maybe they should
the seat open while Hillary Clinton was
president what I'm saying is is that
that sort of power politics has to swing
both ways and then we have to end it
that's the view so actually if you're
sick okay ratso right so you're saying
that one suite and by the way just for
the record I hated that I hated that
they did that not because I wanted some
left nomination whose power politics I
said that at that I said that at the
time I don't like Merrick garland was a
leftist posing as a centrist but I still
was against not considering him however
what you're saying is that what should
we do about it listen once we 20-fold
know we should know I'm lying if
somebody chittim eyes if you weren't in
the eyes of the public doing it with
less from Harvard okay how about very
soon I'm a reason more cynical than I am
how about well I'm sure totally yeah
well give me one sentence okay socialism
will win thanks for having me in Samuel
thanks for revealing yourself I
appreciate it